so first up here for for all four of you
you are playing crime fighting Turtles
here but I know there is a heavy
emphasis on them feeling like real
teenagers in this movie so can you each
tell me something your character does or
says in the movie that made you think
like you know what I would actually in
real life say or do that too
um we mentioned uh like the New York the
New York the New York stereotype of like
the bacon egg and cheese yeah like Tim's
like that's something we genuinely were
joking about before recording and then
they're like you know what say that in
the say that on the like the on the on
the recording so yeah we just added that
in there can confirm you nailed bacon
egg and cheese
we have the approval uh Leo in the movie
says like oh so it's a date completely
like misunderstanding what April is
saying and that's uh that's like me that
is me a lot literally me yeah yeah I
think just adding all the modern day
energy you know being as youthful again
we are so I was like adding a youthful
energy like being excited about you know
improv and all those kind of things and
like playing on their phones in the
middle of the night before going to
sleep uh things like that I'm gonna get
back to that improv I love how you
recorded this movie yeah for me I mean a
lot of us use a lot of language that we
use in our day-to-day lives I mean we we
put ourselves into these characters and
really made them our our own version so
I mean for for Raph particularly uh if I
could think of anything he's always like
all right bro all right bro like I'm
kind of I kind of say that a lot oh my
God bro all right like I'm kind of same
answer with less of the gravel but this
is a gravel but yeah it's the Improv in
this is except like I don't know how you
record an animated movie any other way
after having this experience it's
something else we set the bar I think we
said yeah the best part is like you feel
the difference it makes in the movie
like your energy together it like leaps
off screen and really does make all the
difference with the character chemistry
it was incredible and it's so important
for like the Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles because they are brothers and
you really need to have that translate
to the movie so chemistry the fact that
Seth and Jeff were able to you know make
it happen where we can record in the
same place it was it made a great
product I'm gonna dig into specifics
with that in a minute but first for all
four of you if you got the opportunity
to swap roles and each get the turtle
that you relate to most who would you
each be playing and why do we point out
it would be better to describe this what
am I thinking I was wondering if it
would be better for you to name the
turtle you related to most yourself or
to have the other three name it for you
oh I like the I like the name let's
rename it for you okay all right let's
do that we'll start here which one would
I be I think Leo still I'm supposed to
say I think you could pass her a Mikey
if anything else okay yeah yeah you're
right yeah Mikey thanks for having fun
loving here I'm a fun loving guy all
right who would you be then come on yeah
I would actually like to see you play
with that it's so different from your
microphone okay so there we go thank you
uh Brady Brady you should Brady you
should be Leo let's see what Leo looks
like yeah
I love how you were all cast in this
film but I would happily watch like an
ALT version of the film where you all
SWAP around
the next movie Turtles
there's some sort of like Multiverse
version that would be very in right now
and make all the sense
so you go into this movie I'm sure you
are prepared for it to a t but when
you're playing characters like this
there's always opportunity to discover
things along the way so what is equality
about your turtle that you discovered
during the recording process that you
know wound up being creatively
fulfilling for you to play a bit of a
geek I'm a bit of a nerd but there's
certain things I obsess over and like I
did my research I wanted to I wanted to
immerse myself in the character and and
so I I listened to some K-pop I listen I
watched some anime I really like became
like one of those dweebs like I like
like I became like I became like a very
much a nerd in the in the anime and
K-pop world
that's fine yeah I come from like a
little high school like School theater
background so just that like seeing that
Mikey I was just like so ironic
um and just like certain things that he
loves like waffle Pizza like out of all
things I'm like I think New York it's
somewhere you can actually get a waffle
pizza so I'm definitely gonna try that
when I pop out there waffle piece that
doesn't sound half bad to me yeah I
would try that yeah
um I I think for me I I think Raphael
something that like I learned from him
was that that he does have a heart in
him believe it or not I mean a lot of
people just stereotype him as just this
hot head that just is like always angry
like always yelling but like when I was
taking the approach when I when I knew
that I was initially getting into this
role I really wanted to add some some
heart and some comedy into him and have
people relate to him and understand him
a little bit better I think for me it
was more so in the process of recording
like finding the journey to leadership
rather than just being there already I
think in the first few sessions I came
on I think very like on top of things is
Leo and I think Jeff had the great
direction of like well let him figure
things out a bit you know he's the
youngest Ninja Turtles like we've seen
on screen right I think so like well
real teenagers so seeing him figure that
out in instead of just having it like
just in his heart I think it was a great
journey for him to go on I dig that art
quite a bit it plays quite well actually
just pointed out I think Mike is the
youngest turtle ever yeah like look at
that I'm only 15 but when I was
recording I was like as it should be I
love all iterations of Ninja Turtles but
the vibe in this felt so right and true
to me so going back to the Improv now
can you each give me an example of a
time during your recording sessions when
a scene partner surprised you and it
wound up bringing something out of your
own performance that you didn't expect
well I think always recording with these
guys you never know what you're gonna
get yeah and I think that was one of the
things that Jeff and Seth were like
looking for and they definitely got it
because that was one of the things like
coming into the movie like and seeing it
and screen is so amazing but before I
was kind of like how was all of this
because we're always we're on top of
each other like you know with lines and
everything so I'm just kind of like how
is this gonna come out so it's just like
I think one thing that surprised me was
just like I think these two like their
banter is so crazy because they always
had them like looking at each other like
in the booth so it's kind of like like
the the nerd with the like the brains
and the bronze going at each other I
think that was one of the things that
surprised me how well it came out yeah I
I I think for me just just being around
these three guys and the level that they
record at is just so so high and it's
like they they're just on like even with
all the Improv like it it was hard for
me to like keep up sometimes and I
really had to like stay attentive if I
really wanted to stay in it like really
because once we get into the character
and once we're like improving and going
in you can't you can't snap out of it or
you'll fall out of the scene so like for
them to always always be able to just
snap at a finger go into that like like
you just really got to keep that hyper
focus and and I really learned a lot and
and I feel like I definitely grew as as
a voice actor just working with these
three amazing actors I think an example
I can reference
um is like when we were I'm sorry for
bringing this back to like the New York
scene because I remember it too
yeah like initially it was just I was
supposed to say the line I'm a cabbie
from the Bronx I love these turtles that
was it but I remember I was like that's
kind of like that's kind of boring like
it's a good line and I was like a cat I
was like I'm a Gabby I got I got a
puffer like and then they're like Jeff
was like I like that like and then and
then when we started talking about we're
like and then NYX was like yeah yeah
yeah you can let me get a bacon egg and
cheese and then they all like
and so it really adds a good like a good
little a little inside joke that we had
which is actually in the movie which is
really cool yeah I love how that scene
just exploded because it really did
start out with one small line and then
it turned it it was just like it wasn't
even supposed to be like really anything
it was just like one small little line
yeah but what I was gonna say oh too
what I was gonna say to answer your
question about like something that
surprised me in the booth like Leo and
RAF butt heads like that's just in their
nature and dude you would get someone
like Digs at me like in The Improv I
don't remember like specific but I'll be
like damn don't get off my back and like
I think it would come out yeah it ends
with uh one semi-silly person questions
I liked talking about pizza but also
food in general so for like real you
what is your version of the Turtle's
Pizza where you could eat that one thing
like all day every day and eat it in any
variation you can come up with oh that's
a good question mine is peanut butter
sandwiches any type of peanut butter you
have fluffer Nutters like
Alfredo like Alfredo yeah like pasta I
have this horrible habit of like uber
eating all the time I don't know if you
can like um what is it like verb eyes
yeah okay I'm working I'm making that a
bird but I have a horrible habit I've
just been ordering Wings all the time
recently so it's like yeah I I go this
one place and I'm trying out all their
flavors it's like I need to stop it's
it's hurting my mind I need to stop it's
a problem it's a problem yeah mine would
definitely be I'm very into spice but I
always get like spicy chicken sandwiches
like shout out to Jason like I I be like
you trying to get sponsored hey if you
can if you can hit me up like I'll be
down like let me know anyways uh I would
definitely make that a I'll make
like a pizza like sandwich like that
would be so sick like just like because
I think I'm thinking like you gotta go
more than just a chicken sandwich I
would want to like maybe add a little
like combine a pizza because Pizza is a
great food I I see where the turtles are
coming from and then you add chicken
sandwich like you know I'm thinking like
a Big Mac but with like pizza
but you would eat that every day
my entire life the fact that we have a
new movie that just makes me so happy
and like feel like I first discovered
Turtles again is really that's awesome